hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are going to be making well not
waffles but this is a waffle maker I've
never had a waffle maker before and the
only time I've ever used one was I like
a hotel restaurant and then it
overflowed and it was just a disaster so
I thought I think I need one we're not
making waffles in the waffle maker today
we're gonna make an omelet so let's
unbox this is like for an unboxing part
cooking video the best of both worlds
Wow so I like that these have removable
plates so I can just throw these in the
dishwasher after I make a mess oh oh
look at this super fancy doesn't feel
very fancy oh nice
well I guess I'm gonna wash these first
because I'd like to try my omelette and
I feel like you should always wash
things when you first get them because
there's from Melda hide there's rat poop
poison very dangerous substances on your
items okay fresh and clean if your may
directions on the floor so I'm just
enough to try to figure this out using
my own small mind only operate with
grids in place it's like a puzzle oh
[Music]
yeah here we go oh whoops okay this is
easy
there we go Oh perfect okay cool it
looks good oh no oh oh I don't talk
about it everything worked out perfect
and easy so we're gonna make an omelet
today in the waffle maker so for our
omelet of course you're gonna need eggs
I'm actually really good at making
breakfast I've never made an omelet like
this but one day I will make an actual
real breakfast video for you and you
guys will see that yeah I'm pretty good
we're gonna be using a nice Mexican
blend cheese today for our omelet
I wanted tomatoes for my omelet but
these were the only tomatoes that they
had on Amazon so there are little tiny
ones so we'll just try to figure out and
see what we can do with that well I
think that's about all we're gonna have
in our omelet maybe a little salt a
little pepper some basil a little bit of
garlic we're gonna make it super spicy
I wonder what power I should put it on
do you have any recommendations really
okay so two
yeah we'll do two so usually for my
morning omelettes I like to do two eggs
regular and then one egg white one egg
two you I smell burning it's probably
the freshness of this Hamilton Beach not
sponsored video it's not I bought it on
Amazon go figure
hey Justine do you uh do you leave the
house now do you probably so in my
omelets I like to add a little salt or a
lot more or less the taste some a pepper
that looks good some basil mmm that's a
little much but that's all right
garlic because why not make sure you
don't have any hot dates tonight baby
let's whisk this up this smells so
garlicky think I might overdid it hmm
hmm I think I'm gonna put the cheese
just in it Mike's Mexican blend cheese
Oh delicious if there's one thing that
I've learned about anything in life is
you need to always spray the pan and
spray it well
[Music]
I'm gonna pour this in holy moly
yeah I forgot the tomatoes
okay here we go close it up
[Music]
Oh God Oh God egg is I don't know how
long to do it so I flip it is there a
reason I flip it why do I flip it
[Applause]
this is not what I expected to happen
guess I'll just shave off the side of
our omelet but how long do I think it
tells me when it's ready I mean it's
kind of hard to burn eggs it sounds like
my worst nightmare god this is the wrong
way okay it's it's like I'm gonna unplug
it oh shoot I don't even know I'm not
sure okay wait oh my god what do I do Oh
[Music]
actually for all that it's looking good
I didn't play wow how do I get this out
now oh wow Wow okay so here's the thing
I think it worked but I'm also a little
bit concerned because usually when you
get like a new item like the first thing
that you cook you really shouldn't
really eat it but what do you think
hanger looks good right yeah it's not
bad yeah I think the problem was putting
in the tomatoes at the end you guys I
think those got a little inflated I'm
not really sure what happened but I'm
pretty happy with the result I might as
well just take a little taste of it I
mean what's the worst that can happen oh
my god it's delicious it's actually
really really good
it's like almost the perfect omelet like
I'm not even this is this is me being a
hundred percent
this is your right hand I think that
this is a delicious omelette I'm happy
I'm very happy with the outcome it looks
awful I would definitely not serve this
to guests but if you're ever in a bind
and you're like wow I really have a
waffle maker and I want to make eggs in
it this is what you could do so thanks
for watching let me know in the comments
below if you would like to see me
actually try to make a real omelet and
show you basically what I make every
morning this is not what I make every
morning in this but it's kind of the
same thing just on a pan over there all
right we'll see you guys later hope you
have a wonderful day wakey wakey eggs
and Bakey
[Music]